MARK MIRCHANDANI:
There wouldn't be
much point to a
job search solution
without jobs to search for.
In our last video, we talked
about creating companies
using the Google Cloud Talent
Solution Job Search API.
Now, let's talk about how to
create jobs and best practices
for working with them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We'll get started
by creating a job.
You can't make a job
without a company,
so we'll be using a company that
we created in the last video.
There are also a few
required fields we'll need.
First off, we'll need
the company's name,
which is the unique
identifier, not to be
confused with display name.
We'll also need
a requisition ID,
which is a string
that represents
your own unique identifier
for the job, kind
of like external
ID for companies.
This is helpful to
make sure it's easier
to sync the job search API
in your current job solution.
There's also the
title, which is, well,
the display title of the job.
Description is where you put
all the job details and related
information.
You can use HTML and
some markup tags here.
Finally, we'll need at
least one of three fields
under application info--
URIs, emails, or instruction.
These help point job
seekers to where they'll
need to go in order to apply.
URIs and emails
are arrays in case
you have multiple,
while instruction
is an HTML-friendly string
where you can describe
the application process.
Each job could have all three,
but you can't create a job
without having at least one.
With all those fields,
you can create a job,
so let's look at some code.
The code structure
should look pretty
similar to our other samples,
but let's walk through the bits
to create the job.
We need to include the project
ID and the company name
here so we can use it when
we first define the job.
We'll hardcode it
just for this snippet.
Here, we're passing
in the job when we
call the API with jobs.create.
Again, pretty similar
to creating a company.
And here's where we
actually define the job
and set those required fields.
We've got the company name,
which was set up above,
as well as the
requisition ID, which
is the string we can use to more
easily map the job to our job
system.
After that, there's the title,
description, and in this case,
we provided a link for the
application information.
So from here, we'll
create the job.
And the API knows which
company it belongs to,
so we pass in the company name.
After running that code,
here's part of the response.
We'll see the new
job was created,
and it has the same property
values that we passed in,
as well as our
unique name that we
can use when referencing a job.
Now that we can
create jobs, what
happens when we try
to create a job that's
already in the system?
As you might expect,
you'll get an error,
because job duplicates
aren't allowed.
Duplicates are determined
by three fields--
company name, requisition
ID, and language code.
We provided company
name and requisition ID
when creating the job.
Language code is
an optional field
that will represent the language
based on the job description,
and it defaults to
en us if not set.
As long as the combination of
these three fields is unique,
the job won't be
treated as a duplicate.
So that's the basics
for creating jobs.
We can also get a job
to see the details,
delete a job to get rid
of it, and patch a job
to update any properties.
Just like companies, you should
pass in an update mask, which
is a string of
comma-separated properties
that you want to update.
There's a few more
details about why
that's important in
the company's video.
We can also list jobs to see
all the jobs in the system.
This is just a simple list
without any filtering,
so it's probably better
saved for any administrative
functionality.
This code is the modified
version of our list companies
code that now shows
companies and jobs.
We'll loop through each
company, and then list jobs
for that company by filtering
on the company's name.
Pretty simple, but a
great starting point
to making sure that
you know the jobs
and companies in your system.
There's quite a few more
fields when dealing with jobs,
but they're optional.
Let's look at some of
the more common ones.
And you can always check on
the docs to see the full list.
Each job can have an array
of up to 50 addresses, which
are passed in as strings.
Just like companies,
the API will
create a read-only property for
each job, called derived info,
that looks at
addresses you pass in
as well as the parent
company's information
to geolocate each job.
This is all powered by the
Google Maps Geocoding API.
So if it works there,
it'll work here.
There's also a
posting region which
lets you specify how strict the
location matching for the job
needs to be.
For instance, if the posting
region is set to nation,
this job will show up
for a search in jobs
that match the same country.
Administrative area
depends on the country
but represents areas like
states, for United States,
and prefectures for Japan.
Telecommute means the job
allows for remote work,
and the location
is less relevant.
There are also some
fields to help you
talk more about the job
itself, such as job benefits,
compensation info, employment
types, and degree types.
Each of these have their
own object, or enum,
to get the most accurate data.
But they're all
pretty simple fields.
There's even custom attributes.
So you can provide your
own key value pairs
and do some advanced
searching, which we'll
talk about in a later video.
However, these are all useful
to help jobs searchers get
better results.
There are also a few properties
specific to the job posting
itself.
These are all strings
that represent timestamps.
The fields postingCreateTime
and postingUpdateTime
are read-only
fields that let you
know when the job posting
was created and most recently
updated, respectively.
jobStartTime and jobEndTime
are useful for contracting
or seasonal jobs where you
might have specific timing
requirements.
postingPublishTime
represents when
this job was most
recently published,
while postingExpireTime
is the timestamp for when
the job posting expires.
By default, the expiration
time is set to 30 days
after the job was created.
We definitely recommend
explicitly setting
the expiration date
to what makes the most
sense for your business.
For example, if you update
a job but don't include
a new expiration time, it
will refresh the expiration
to 30 days from the
time of the update.
If you want to get
around that, explicitly
set a new expiration
time, or make
sure to use an update mask
without posting expire time.
Expired jobs won't show
up in search results
or when calling list,
but you can still
get the properties of an expired
job by using get, and in fact,
update it with patch.
It's even possible to update
the posting expire time
to unexpire a job.
That patch may fail if
there's another open job
with the same company name,
requisition ID, and language
code, so make sure
that you handle
any errors that come back.
Also, if a job is
expired for long enough,
or you have too many expired
jobs compared to open jobs,
expired jobs start to
get permanently deleted.
Remember, the job search API
is a search index for jobs.
So if you want any
permanent record keeping,
you should do that in the
job solution directly.
That's a brief overview to help
you start loading companies
and jobs.
With all that data,
there's only one thing
to talk about in
our next video--
performing searches.
Thanks for watching.
And remember, when
looking for talent,
it's OK to keep your
head in the cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]